if we lose this one which he will it's  minus one versus plus four  that's a long long road ahead  tough day  for rapport and his fans  ding  ding don't manage to win a game does he  like he he went for this  but now the bishop disappeared  why should it be better  i don't think it was bigger for white  you can go queenie five for example yeah  not a six plate  but yeah the white structure is no  longer superior joe collected his fourth  victory in the tournament  congratulations very impressive  performance  job well done  yeah  and the sad story of today of richie  because  it was it was not a game which was good  to be in  no he was brave but  somewhat reckless and  it's it's like when you wish  and you're confusing with the  alternative  i mean  you're wishing that you can play on but  actually your brain says  that you should agree to draw and then  your heart  makes you to move on because you want to  win somehow give you an opportunity